in deutschland ist ernst der in die
teuerungswelle hat auch die
supermarktregale erreicht die
lebensmittelpreise sind zum teil
explosionsartig gestiegenen 43 prozent
mehr für butter
33 prozent mehr für nudeln 65 prozent
mehr für rapsöl das sind alles die
fakten zu kennen sie mit einer dickeren
brieftasche kann man sicherlich die
rechnung im supermarkt stimmen aber die
frisuren der paketbote und den
rentnerinnen fällt diese entwicklung du
wirklich auf die füße liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen bei mir in brandenburg
brennt es besonders jeder dritte
brandner hat weniger als 2300 euro
brutto monatlich zur verfügung jeder
dritte und sie können sich ausmalen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen was diese
mondpreise in den supermarkt für die
menschen mit wenig geld bedeutet
teuerungswelle ist zum teil ja man kann
sagen in finanzieller überlebenskampf
geworden jeder sechste lässt laut einer
insa umfrage bereits mahlzeiten
ausfallen die preiserhöhung dieser woche
scheint auch noch nicht das ende dieser
fahnenstange zu sein laut ifo institut
planen neun von zehn lebensmittelhändler
weitere preiserhöhungen gleichzeitig und
das spielte heute vormittag schon rolle
stoßen die ehrenamtlerinnen bei den
tafeln an ihre grenzen weil die
lebensmittelspenden für den großen
andrang nicht mehr ausreichen und meine
damen und herren dagegen müssen wir
etwas tun und vor allen dingen meine
damen und herren sie der
mehrheitskoalition
im haus müssen was tun werden die ferien
entlastungs pakete sind absolut
unzureichend und vor allen dingen haben
sie sich eher auf die energiepreise
konzentriert und was sagen sie den
menschen draußen die sich kein obst und
kein gemüse mehr leisten können deshalb
erwarte ich von ihnen als position dass
sie das endlich auch zur chefsache in
dieser politischen arbeit machen wenn
meine damen und herren
der schnellste und der pragmatischste
weg ist die befreiung der
grundnahrungsmittel von der
mehrwertsteuer seit april ist das in der
europäischen union möglich und es gibt
keinen ernährungspolitische naber
sonstigen grund mehr
grundnahrungsmittel mit mehrwertsteuer
pauschal um sieben prozent zu versteuern
das sieht auch der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister so das
sieht das umweltbundesamt zu und da
sehen ob wir als dienst fraktion so und
auf der anderen seite
und auf der anderen seite macht der
bundesfinanzminister bei jeder
preiserhöhung noch kasse 7 prozent auf
250 gramm butter für 230 sind eben mehr
als sieben prozent auf 1 60 noch vor
drei monaten und die mehrwertsteuer
meine damen und herren der fdp sie ist
auch ein preistreiber geworden und
stoppen sie das mit ihren mehrheiten
meine damen und herren ihre
steuerentlastung
entlastet breite mehrheit der
bevölkerung vom busfahrer bis zum
armutsrenten und die hälfte der
bevölkerung
mit kleinem geldbeutel wird durch keine
andere steuer mehr belastet als durch
diese mehrwertsteuer und die aussetzung
im rahmen eines entlastungs paketes
ernährung ist deshalb nicht nur eine
zielgerichtete und programmatische und
eine pragmatische lösung sondern vor
allen dingen auch eine gerechte
maßnahmen meine damen und herren um das
sicherzustellen
dass die aussetzung der mehrwertsteuer
auch in voller höhe an die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
weitergegeben wird fordern wir die
einrichtung einer preisbeobachtung
stelle in unserem antrag die die
entwicklung der erzeuger und
lebensmittelpreise in der gesamten kette
der bewirtschaftung überwacht meine
damen und herren werden sie nichts tun
wird die spaltung in diesem land zu
nehmen das kann keiner wollen machen sie
was und insofern würde ich gerne werben
für unseren antrag vielen dank
[Applaus]
soweit christian görke der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
linksfraktion auf ihn folgten dem
klüssendorf spd fraktion und mitglied im
finanzausschuss
frau präsidentin liebe regelungen
kollegen der demokratischen fraktion
herr görg ich möchte ja zunächst einmal
eine analyse zu stimmen und auch nochmal
auf die situation eingehen die wirklich
dramatisch ist wir haben eine inflation
von knapp acht prozent der höchste wert
seit über fünf jahrzehnten
wir haben energie preissteigerungen von
über 40 prozent und gerade auch im
lebensmittelbereich steigt drei
steigerung von 11 prozent die besonders
bei den grundnahrungsmitteln wie butter
mehl und öl weit über 40 50 teilweise 60
prozent im moment ausmachen sie haben
auch mit der analyse recht dass gerade
die kleinen und mittleren einkommen
davon betroffen sind denn wenn man sich
einmal anschaut was das verfügbare
haushaltseinkommen wofür das eigentlich
ausgegeben wird dann sind es ja eben
genau diese dinge 40 prozent für wohnen
und energie 15 prozent für lebensmittel
15 prozent für mobilität dass es nur der
durchschnitt wir können davon ausgehen
dass es bei den kleinen und mittleren
einkommen deutlich höher ist deswegen
eins ist klar wir werden uns kümmern wir
haben in der vergangenheit darum
gekümmert mit den leistungspaketen und
wir werden uns auch in der zukunft darum
kümmern diese menschen besonders zu
entlasten
ein ein klub an der stelle weil es mir
doch ein anliegen auch ist das noch mal
zu erwähnen denn es ist ein größeres
problem in unserer gesellschaft wir
haben auch menschen die von dieser krise
profitieren wir haben hohe vermögen die
weiter anwachsen wir haben eine große
ungerechtigkeit in unserer gesellschaft
und ich möchte an dieser stelle doch
nochmal erwähnen dass wir das auch nicht
aus dem blick verlieren dass wir
gemeinsam an lösungen daran arbeiten
auch die menschen mit höheren vermögen
stärker in die verantwortung zu nehmen
und dort für mehr gerechtigkeit und für
den sozialen frieden zu sorgen aber wir
sprechen heute über kurzfristige
lösungen ich habe eben schon erwähnt wie
haben entlastungs paket in höhe von 30
bis 40 milliarden euro gemeinsam mit fdp
und grünen auf den weg gebracht wir
müssen erstmal abwarten wie die sich
auswirken wir haben im moment noch keine
werte darüber wie sie wirklich ihre
entlassung auch entfalten dass nur ein
euro ticket läuft gerade die haben den
tank rabatt von dem wir zumindest noch
nicht wissen inwiefern er wirklich
weitergegeben wird aber es ist so dass
wir einfach diese pakete natürlich
erstmal abwarten müssen und dass der
deutsche bundeskanzler ja jetzt
richtigerweise auch eingeladen hat zur
konzertierten aktion dass wir gemeinsam
auch vorangehen diese beiden maßnahmen
sind ja sozusagen zum einen ergriffen
zum anderen eingeladen ich finde schon
dass das aktivität ist die man auch zur
kenntnis nehmen muss und die man nicht
einfach wegdiskutieren kann
wenn wir nun über die beiden
vorliegenden anträge bzw auch über die
beschlussempfehlung sprechen dann möchte
ich sagen dass der antrag der linke aus
meiner sicht schon konsequent und
glaubwürdig ist dagegen der achte mal
wieder nicht sie sind rückwärtsgewandt
klimafreundlich und sogar
europarechtswidrig zum erneuten male wir
haben's ja im ausschuss diskutiert wie
einst hier diskutiert sie sind immer
noch nicht auf die idee gekommen ihre
forderungen mal anzupassen rechtswidrig
vor allem auch die abschaffung der co2
steigt weiß ich welche ziele sie damit
verfolgen das ziel die menschen wirklich
zu entlassen das verfolgen sie damit auf
jeden fall nicht
beim spreche ich denn noch heute für
eine ablehnung es gibt eigentlich drei
punkte warum wir im moment nicht der
auffassung sind dass sich der antrag
sozusagen lohnt als maßnahme in einem
weiteren entlastungspaket zunächst
einmal ist er nicht wirksam erstens
nicht wirksam weil die inflation kein
zustand ist sondern ein prozess eine
einmalige preissenkung würde vielleicht
für einen kurzen effekt sorgen aber es
würde natürlich langfristig nicht nichts
nützen weil die preise weiter ansteigen
außerdem ist es ein funktionierender
markt auf der einen seite aber andere
seite ist die umgebung im moment so dass
ich als unternehmer natürlich angesichts
der auch in zukunft anzunehmenden
preissteigerung natürlich nicht sofort
reagieren würde sondern eher mal ein
risiko für die zukunft einfach mit
einkalkulieren wurde und die preise
lassen würde wie sie sind einfach um
mich da auch abzusichern für
gegebenenfalls zukünftige
kostensteigerungen deswegen muss man
einfach da im moment von ausgehen dass
die mitnahmeeffekte so hoch sind dass
die preissenkungen nicht auf den
konsumenten umgelegt werden
ein zweiter punkt ist dass ich massive
zweifel an der aktuellen kategorie
kategorisierung habe was
grundnahrungsmitteln dieser republik
sind und vielleicht mag es auch an dem
gremium dieser entscheiden und
entscheider liegen aber im moment ist es
so dass wachteleier froschschenkel und
trüffel zu den grundnahrungsmitteln
gehören pflanzliche milch wie sojamilch
zum beispiel oder champignons im glas
allerdings nicht ich weiß nicht ob das
der richtige ansatzpunkt ist jetzt vier
mit einer befreiung der mehrwertsteuer
grundnahrungsmittel zu kommen wenn wir
doch in den kategorien eigentlich noch
gar nicht klar sind aus meiner sicht
wäre es viel sinnvoller mal wenn man mal
unabhängig von der inflationsbekämpfung
denkt sondern grundsätzlich über die
mehrwertsteuer nachdenkt eine neue
kategorisierung vorzunehmen und das den
wahren kosten den wirklichen kosten dem
klimafaktoren den echten umweltfaktoren
anzupassen
und ein letzter punkt das geld kann nur
einmal ausgegeben werden deswegen müssen
wir genau überlegen welche maßnahmen und
aus unserer sicht bieten sich da
möglicherweise auch andere maßnahmen an
einmal zuschüsse die direkt bei den
menschen ankommen denn man muss ganz
ehrlich sagen die ausstellung des
nächsten haushaltes und ich freue mich
dass der finanzminister auch der debatte
wobei wohnt wird sowieso glaube ich eine
anspruchsvolle aufgabe auch eine
kreative aufgabe denn bei beibehaltung
der schuldenbremse zusätzlichen
entlastung koalitionsprojekte
durchsetzten bundeswehr und keine
steuererhöhungen da also ich weiss
events in mathematik nobelpreis gäbe
dann wäre es auf jeden fall ein
angepeiltes ziel vom finanzminister dass
damit zu erfüllen man müsste schon sagen
man könnte fast zaubern also eines
dieser themen dass man vielleicht
sowieso aufgehen das heißt lasst uns bei
der erlassung pakete wirklich gucken
welche maßnahmen ankommen und dann
gemeinsam gute regierungspolitik machen
und mich solche anträge stellen vielen
dank
lissendorf war das und sie haben es
gesehen die staats und regierungschefs
der eu sowie der west balkan länder
haben sich schon zum familienfoto
aufgestellt wir erwarten jetzt in kürze
dann die pressekonferenz von ursula von
der leyens michelle und auch der
französische präsident emanuel marco ist
angekündigt solange bleiben wir aber
natürlich hier noch in der debatte fritz
güntzler spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
im vereinigten deutschland zuletzt
konnten wir so was in der krisenphase
1973 1974 von da ist es wichtig dass wir
uns als parlament und auch die regierung
sich damit beschäftigt wie wir gerade
die niedrigen und mittleren einkommen
entlasten können und jede
entlastungsmaßnahmen es wird ihr das
belastungspaket immer wieder genannt
muss sich aber auch messen lassen daran
ob das ziel gerichtet ist in der glocke
wir haben im ausschuss schon drüber
gesprochen und da haben wir schon
zweifel ob diese maßnahme wirklich dort
ankommt oder nur dort ankommt wo sie
ankommen soll die abschaffung ist
steuersatzes also der satz bei
grundnahrungsmitteln
würde zirka zwölf milliarden euro koste
und wer profitiert von den zwölf
milliarden euro natürlich die von ihnen
auch adressierten niedrigen und
mittleren einkommen aber auch die mit
höheren einkommen relativ sagen sie
tragen die niedrigen einkommen sowieso
höhere umsatzsteuer interessant sind
dann aber auch schon die absoluten
zahlen wenn man auf basis von 2017 sich
das ankunft würde die entlastung für die
unteren zehn prozent einkommensbezieher
gerade mal 74 euro bringen oder 74 wird
gar nicht werten aber für die oberen
zehn prozent fast 180 euro bringen daran
sehen sie dass sie eigentlich absolut
die höher verdienen damit entlasten als
die die sie eigentlich treffen wollen
von daher sind wir der auffassung dass
diese maßnahme nicht zielgenau ist wir
werden weiter das muster also die
maßnahmen müssen sich danach richten und
wir sind dagegen weil eben diese
vergünstigung einfachen breiter schuss
ist und betrifft eben alle und sie haben
zwar die preisbeobachtung stelle
angeführt es wird mitnahmeeffekte geben
das haben wir als
regierungskoalition auch erleben müssen
dass die mehrwertsteuersenkung des
jahres 20 20 von 19 auf 16 prozent von
sieben auf fünf prozent auch nur zu 60
prozent weitergegeben wurde es gab also
mitnahmeeffekte und die wird es in
diesen fällen auch geben und ich glaube
nicht dass sie unbedingt die
lebensmittelkonzerne subventionieren
wollen und verbände die menschen dort
noch verbessern würden übrigens glaube
ich auch wieder wahr den land ankommen
würde bei den produzenten dies auch
dringend notwendig klette herr kollege
und vielleicht ist das genau die frage
die in herstellen wollte möchten sie die
zu lassen natürlich
muss sich freunde suchen und ein
bisschen aufpassen auch das bestellt
waren vielen dank frau präsidentin
vielen dank auch kollegin soll dass sie
diese frage zu lassen ich höre ja eher
eine sehr skeptische auffassung zur
absenkung oder aussetzung der mehrwert
schaffenden raus sie sind ja mitglied
der cdu csu fraktion und deshalb würde
mich mal interessieren wie sie das
gerade diskutieren in der fraktion war
ja der vorsitzende der cdu csu von der
cdu deutschlands ministerpräsident ob
söder dieses jahr als eine maßnahme
gerade flüssig vorschlag hat vielen dank
wir haben ja darauf hingewiesen dass wir
eine gemeinsame fraktion von cdu und csu
sind und ich habe auch vernommen dass
der csu vorstand einen grundsätzlichen
klugen beschluss gefasst hat mit 15
maßnahmen die tatsächlich zur entlastung
beitragen würden aber sie haben richtig
meine borghorst so verstanden dass sich
mit der einen maßnahme nicht so
einverstanden bin weil ich sie eben
nicht für zielgerichtet halte und sie
einfach zu teuer ist und eben eben alle
betrifft und das ist eine gießkanne und
das sollten wir nicht machen und diese
diskussion führen wir ganz offen mit
unseren kollegen der csu und werden sie
auch weiter mit dem erfolgreichen
ministerpräsident des freistaates bayern
führen
aber zurück zum thema ich finde
interessant und wichtig ja kollegen
lösen darauf angesprochen ich glaube
sollten alle mal gemeinsam jetzt auch
genug haben vielleicht mal an das
umsatzsteuerrecht insgesamt wieder ran
zu geben jörg hat auch darauf
hingewiesen dass wir im april 22 eine
änderung der richtung wir haben die uns
neue mehr flexibilität schafft wir
können 0 sätze machen mit vorsteuerabzug
wir können zwar mäßig die steuersätze
machen wir haben einen umfassenden
katalog von in der anlage 3 system
richtlinie von 55 punkten die man raus
sehen könnte und dann die kuriositäten
sich an einige genannt das ist ja wie
wird wildschwein sind 19 prozent und das
hausschwein 7 prozent das kann man alles
nicht nachvollziehen von daher wäre es
wirklich mal des schweizers wehrt sich
dieses themas anzunehmen das wird nicht
einfach weil immer jemand genau sein
ermäßigten steuersatz retten will aber
wie kann ich ihnen sagen als herrn jung
begleiten sie gerne bei einem
konstruktiven prozess das jetzt zu
nutzen das ganze thema zu nutzen das
umsatzsteuerrecht in diesem punkt zu
reformieren
wir haben übrigens das ganze auch
begleitet von einer kleinen anfrage wo
wir genau die bundesregierung fragen und
dem bundesfinanzminister fragen was denn
in diesen punkten alles gemacht werden
können ich will darauf hinweisen zum
abschluss der rede dass wir wie gesagt
diese maßnahme nicht für
zielgerichtetheit ich halte herr kollege
studie zwischen zwischenrufen das thema
der kalten progression für viel
sinnvoller sie sind einen richtigen
schritt gegangen indem sie den
grundfreibetrag erhöht haben sie sind
aber nicht die weiteren schritte
gegangen dass sie die gericht erklärte
angepasst haben wir haben noch eine
steilere kurve in der untersten
progressionszone als wir müssen an den
gesamten tariffragen glaube das würde
die menschen gerade mit niedrigen und
mittleren einkommen entlasten natürlich
auch die höheren einkommen ist klar aber
das ist ja eine verschiebung von rechts
das wir machen sollen und ich glaube
auch das thema der pendlerpauschale muss
noch mal auf den tisch wir haben auf 38
cent die erhöht das war auch vorschlag
der union zu einem gezielt zeitpunkt als
ich noch nicht die seminare preise
hatten und wenn ich sehe das sind 38
cent pro entfernungskilometer sind 19
cent pro gefahrenen kilometer und wenn
der adac berechnet dass die kosten ist
durchschnitt liegt bei 67 prozent liegen
dann sieht man dass diese 38 cent nicht
ausreichen und das sind meistens pendler
die auch nicht ob das noch ein euro
ticket zurückgreifen können weil sie ihm
gar keine busverbindung haben oder eine
u bahn vor ort haben also von daher
glaube ich gehen sie bitte noch einmal
an die pendlerpauschale und das wäre ein
punkt der wirklich zielgerichtet würde
und die menschen die aufs auto
angewiesen sind entlastet und dass wir
mehr wert als das was sie hier
vorschlagen und einer großen gießkanne
einmal zwölf milliarden auszuschütten
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
fritz künstler war es für die
unionsfraktion nächste rednerin ist
katharina beck die finanzpolitische
sprecherin der grünen fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger
haben wir in deutschland ein problem mit
massiven preissteigerungen ja sehr sehr
groß ist dieses problem
gurken beispielsweise sind über 40
prozent teurer geworden alle
lebensmittel sind durchschnittlich über
zehn prozent teurer geworden
und wie sollen sich dass menschen deren
hat vier sätze beispielsweise nicht
gestiegen sind oder menschen die auch
wie manager 70 80 stunden wochen haben
aber das in drei jobs erarbeiten müssen
und dann vielleicht sogar noch
aufstocken müssten wie sollen die sich
das leisten
dieses problem das wirklich massiv und
viag regierungen das haben jetzt schon
so viele gesagt haben wirklich mit
riesigen entlastungs paketen steuern wir
schon dagegen aber es ist wichtig
zielgerichtet und auch mit soliden
staatsfinanzen uns für die zukunft
richtig aufzustellen und die antwort
jetzt mit einer einzelmaßnahme zu
glauben das problem bei den
lebensmittelpreisen zu lösen ich hatte
gerade eben schon gesagt die gurken
preise beispielsweise in vielen anderen
im zweistelligen bereich angestiegen
selbst wenn das zu 100% weitergegeben
würde würden wir das nicht komplett
teilen das problem ist viel größer
kommt sie denn auch an
käme so eine maßnahme denn auch an
die studien variieren da das ist nicht
komplett nachvollziehbar aber selbst
wenn man an dass ungefähr 60 dann kommt
das diw hat bei der letzten
mehrwertsteuersenkung von 50 prozent
gesprochen manche sprechen von 70
prozent im lebensmittelbereich wir
wissen es einfach nicht aber selbst wenn
da was weitergegeben wird ungefähr 60
prozent
können wir es uns leisten dass dann die
restlichen 40%
an die handelsketten die in der choriner
pandemie wirklich große
umsatzsteigerungen verbuchen konnten
dass dann das wären 800 millionen bis 2
milliarden euro dass die dort an lampen
würden und uns fehlen würden für andere
gezielte entlastungsmaßnahmen die
meinung dieser koalition ist nein das
können wir uns so nicht leisten wir
müssen gezielt helfen und die antwort
die angriffe
kann nur sein dass wir eben schauen ihre
künstler hat das ja auch selbst noch mal
gesagt und viele andere wir brauchen
diese entlastungen nicht das heißt wir
müssen die hat hier regelsätze
gegebenenfalls angeben wie oft kann man
sich das nicht leisten und vor allen
dingen dürfen wir aber dann auch nicht
vergessen da ist es immer einfach die
menschen zu erreichen weil sie sind
schon im system aber diejenigen diese
wirklich wenig geld verdienen
glücklicherweise haben wir den
grundfreibetrag angehoben
glücklicherweise haben wir die
energiepreis pauschale die aber auch
frei verfügbar für dinge einsetzt da es
die man wirklich braucht und über
pauschale lösungen müssen und sollten
wir weiterhin absenken auch im nächsten
schritt und
ich hatte es heute morgen schon
ausgeführt der wurzel die wurzel allen
übels sind die extrem explodierten
energiepreise das heißt um hier wirklich
mittelfristig abzufedern und auch die
lebensmittelpreise in deutschland wieder
senken die hängen nämlich in deutschland
viel mehr als eine lieferketten noch an
den energiepreisen müssen wir an die
energie rand wir müssen uns
diversifizieren das machen wir wirklich
nicht leichten herzens danach bat zu
fahren aber das muss sein für die
übergangstechnologie denn ausbau der
erneuerbaren der freiheit energien
vorantreiben das machen wir uns da sehr
sehr bitter wir bauen hier das plazet
geben dementoren und drittens wir müssen
ran gehen an die preisbildung das
kartellrecht reformieren dass es
wirklich substanziell hier nicht mehr zu
diesem dieser möglichkeit kommen kann
die preise so zu setzen wie es geschehen
ist 38 prozent sind die energiepreise
gestiegen dass es wirklich exorbitant
und da in diesem oligopolistischen markt
zu gehen auch das noch diese
bundesregierung das heißt kluge
antworten finden nicht einzelmaßnahmen
die dann gar nicht denen nur zugute
kommen dies bräuchten die dann auch zum
teil kollegen kennen
ich bin jedoch haben sie gar nicht mehr
so gut die idee tätig ist und deswegen
machen wir eine kluge in kloten nichts
anders und verlieren uns nicht in
einzelmaßnahmen gegen ende hätten sie
genau und effizient genug sind
herzlichen dank
für die fdp für die fdp fraktion hat
jetzt kein quatsch dass gottschalk ist
finanzpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
verehrte kollegin etwas nachhilfe
zunächst für den kollegen klüssendorf es
am vormittag auch schon hier für einige
kollegen getan was könnt ihr die co2
abgabe mit dem preis zu tun haben ja
gehen sie ins internet schauen sie sich
die tabellen von adac aber auch von öl
gas und anderen anbieter land ab 2022 30
euro pro tonne macht 8,4 cent auf den
liter normalbenzin aus ab 20 23 35 cent
pro tonne sind 98 cent ab 2024 also
geplante inflation seitens der schulden
koalition 45 sind
45 pro tonne 12 6 10 und ab 20.25 dann
haben sie ihr ziel vielleicht erreicht
autofreie straßen
55 10 55 euro pro tonne macht nochmal 15
cent auf die nachhilfe gratis und ich
nehme auch keine 19 prozent umsatzsteuer
mehrwertsteuer auf der kollege kurt
beck ich muss jetzt das nächste mal
machen da richte ich mich mal an sie
werde ich mich mit ihrer rede
auseinandersetzen oder einigen dingen
aber kommen wir zum punkt zunächst mal
zum antrag der linken ich bin wirklich
happy dass die linke das problem
inflation tatsächlich durchdrungen und
verstanden hat und auch einigen guten
antrag stellt warum sage ich habe einen
guten antrag weil die afb wie ehrlich in
der debatte heute vormittag diesen
bereits schon genauso im märz gestellt
hat und was haben sie getan sie haben
ihn nicht zugestimmt das nicht logisch
wir haben das bereits im märz bezahlen
meine damen und herren weil wir erkannt
haben was die inflation für sie dort
oben auf der tribüne bedeutet
[Applaus]
und kommen wir vielleicht auch noch mal
zu fritz güntzler ich finde es immer
schön auch in steuerfragen ist eine
rechts verschiebung in der gesellschaft
durch was schön ist wie eben auch beim
einkommensteuertarif nach rechts zu
rücken ist eben gut und nicht schlecht
das kann man in dieser stelle aussagen
aber kommen wir noch mal zurück wir
müssen natürlich darauf achten dass
diese steuersenkung und auch das haben
wir in unserem antrag noch in unserem
stehen bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern
ankommen entsprechend wir haben auch
hier im hohen hause die schulden
koalition davor gewarnt diesen schritt
wie sie ihn denn wollen zudem haben auch
die kollegen aus der union durchaus
erkannt mahnende worte gesprochen sie
haben es nicht berücksichtigt und jetzt
ist der katzenjammer groß dass die
entlassung meine damen und herren bei
ihnen oben nicht ankommt allerdings hier
liebe kollegen von der linken gebe ich
ihnen heute freiwillig und auch ganz
gratis nachhilfe es gibt monopol märkte
da brauchen wir so eine kontrolle es
gibt bully pole und oligopole meine
damen und herren hier der
lebensmittelmarkt ist sicherlich in
deutschland und das ist auch bekannt
einer der mit dem größten wettbewerb das
heißt ich glaube hier brauchen wir und
da ist ihr antrag verfehlt keine
aussicht in der met wettbewerb im
lebensmittelmarkt auf einem pulli pohl
funktioniert sehr gut wir haben viele
nachfrager viele anbieter und die ketten
liefern sich einen erbitterten
kreiswettbewerb wenn wir das nicht
hätten dann wäre es bei ihnen da oben
auf der tribüne tatsächlich mit dem
preissteigerung noch dramatischer also
soweit das ist mottenkiste dass es
sozialismus am liebsten würden sie
wahrscheinlich die preise auch noch
durchsetzen das wird es mit uns von der
fw fraktion sicherlich nicht geben
und was wir vorschlagen dass es eben
genau das gute deswegen bitte ich
nochmals die union wie heute vormittag
unserem antrag zuzustimmen denn wir
wollen tatsächlich auch die
mehrwertsteuer auf grundnahrungsmittel
senken ja herr kollege klose und ich
habe es auch gestern gesagt wir sagen an
dieser stelle ähnlich wie die polnischen
kollegen die menschen da draußen sind
uns an dieser stelle wichtiger als eine
richtlinie die die mehrwertsteuer für
otto und andere kraftstoffe eben
festsetzt deswegen sagen wir
vorübergehend für sie da draußen auf
null die mehrwertsteuer entsprechen auf
kraftstoffe zu setzen das hilft den
menschen aber nicht ihre zögerliche
haltung und ihr immer wieder verstecken
hinter einer ohnehin verfehlten
europäischen union
ja und wir wollen auch dass brennstoff
handels im emissions- gesetz außer kraft
setzen denn auch hier handelt es sich um
preistreiberei die wir entsprechend
haben meine damen und herren und
deswegen glaube ich es ist sehr
ausgewogen und wäre es auch sehr
vernünftig an die adresse der kollegen
pcs und demnächst beim tarif auf rädern
mit zustimmen da ist die ecc
verschiebung rechts verschiebungen drin
und ich fordere sie auch zu einem
konstruktiven kurs mit unseren anträgen
vielen dank
heike czech war das für die fdp fraktion
gue warten weiterhin auf die
pressekonferenz es gab dort schon einen
tony cragg aber wir warten noch dass die
jeweiligen pressekonferenz im g-ba von
der leyen michelle und im akkord kommen
werden aber auf youtube diese debatte
weiter hier auch zeigen tillmanns man
spricht jetzt für die fdp fraktion
der agrarrohstoff rande global ist sie
die verwerfungen auf den internationalen
märkten auch bei uns zu spüren
unmittelbar nach dem russischen angriff
erreichte der weizenpreis an den
europäischen börsen neue rekordhöhen
nachdem er bereits zuvor in der nähe der
höchststände des vergangenen jahrzehnts
notierte auf die verfügbarkeit von
pflanzenölen hat der große auswirkungen
usain ist einer der weltweit größten
produzenten und exporteure von
sonnenblumenöl die verknappung führt zu
höheren preisen für rohstoffe und
vorprodukte so dass lebensmittel
weltweit und auch in deutschland teurer
werden jeder von uns kann dieses
phänomen aktuell hautnah in den
lebensmittelmärkten beobachten und
betroffen sind davon natürlich vor allem
die menschen mit kleinerem geldbeutel
weil sein besonders hohen anteil ihres
haushaltseinkommens für nahrungsmittel
aufwenden in den heutigen tagen müssen
wir immer mehr menschen ihre euros es
zweimal beim lebensmittelkauf umdrehen
und manche müssen dabei anstellen sparen
dann das eigentlich kaum noch möglich
ist die bundesregierung und die als
ampel sehen dass wir haben das gesehen
haben den handlungsbedarf erkannt und
deshalb in den vergangenen wochen
bereits und das ist ja schon
angesprochen worden umfangreiche
entlastungs paket geschnürt das war
wichtig weil wir damit den menschen
diesem land wieder mehr
handlungsspielraum in diesen schwierigen
zeiten geben könnten
zudem zwei anträgen die mehrwertsteuer
ist eine enorm wichtige steuer seit
ihrer einführung vor 50 jahren ist sie
aber auch unübersichtlich und
widersprüchlich geworden der kollege
zorn hat das in einer der letzten
debatten wieder führende ja dauernd
einmal sehr plastisch beschrieben und
ich freue mich auch dass der kollege
künstler das heute angesprochen hat dann
müsste man mal grundsätzlich daran gehen
warum ist die mehrwertsteuer in diesem
zustand war in den letzten fünf
jahrzehnten zwei jahrzehnten eine unzahl
von anträgen gehabt haben und eigentlich
zu viele davon angenommen haben und uns
zu wenig um die systematik dieser steuer
an sich gekümmert haben daher freue ich
mich über ihre ankündigung dabei haben
wir viel zu tun
deswegen muss man diese dauer dieses
ausdauernd wieder durchs dorf treiben
mal von rechts mal von links heute im
hufeisen bogen ich glaube das ist nicht
die richtige antwort ganz konkret zu den
anträgen 7 kollege von den linken ich
weiß dass sie glauben dass das geld auf
den bäumen wächst aber sie hätten sich
wenigstens die arbeit machen können mal
kurz zu berechnen was das bedeutet was
das bedeutet denn die antwort müssen sie
auch geben die antwort müssen sie geben
wo sie das geld dann hier nehmen wollen
sogar für eine maßnahme die so wenig
zielgenauigkeit aufweist
aber
immerhin ist ja antrag ein bisschen
sorgfältiger als der antrag von den
kollegen von der afg was mit ihr in
ihrem antrag stört ist neben der
interpunktion die inhaltliche
unschlüssigkeit insbesondere im
energiebereich
sie wollen sie wollen keine erneuerbaren
energien in deutschland aber sie wollen
auch kein wasserstoff importieren weil
sie abhängigkeiten fürchten und was
wollen sie an der stelle haben sie
wollen die abhängigkeit von russland
erhalten das ist wirklich das für dich
blanker unsinn und geben sie mir bitte
zu dass wir das nicht mittragen wollen
das ist doch klar
[Applaus]
kollegin frauke heiligenstadt ist jetzt
die nächste rednerin für die
spd-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ohne zweifel die inflation ist
mit 7,9 prozent im mai
2022 im vergleich zum vorjahresmonat
sehr hoch sie ist insbesondere für viele
menschen die nur über ein geringes
einkommen verfügen deutlich zu hoch
hedwig teurer sind speisefette speiseöle
über 38 prozent fleisch und fleischwaren
über 16 prozent molkereiprodukte und
eier über 13% und brot und
getreideerzeugnisse auch immer noch über
zehn prozent im vergleich zum mai 2021
gerade für meine fraktion ist das sehr
alarmierend wir sind sehr besorgt
darüber dass die inflation insbesondere
im bereich der energie und der
grundnahrungsmittel so hoch ist weil
gerade diese bereiche nicht von den
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern
umgangen werden können natürlich braucht
fast jeder haushalt kraftstoff bereits
energie
abgesehen von energieautarken haushalten
dieses ja noch nicht so viele gibt
genauso ist auch jeder haushalt auf
grundnahrungsmittel angewiesen
insbesondere bezieherinnen und bezieher
kleinerer einkommen werden hier auch
proportional stärker belastet als
menschen mit höheren einkommen
und genau deshalb ist es wichtig jetzt
geeignete maßnahmen für bezieherinnen
und bezieher von kleineren einkommen zu
diskutieren und dann auch vorzuschlagen
und umzusetzen
und man kann nicht oft genug darauf
hinweisen
diese bundesregierung hat bereits ein
entlastungspaket in einer größenordnung
von mehr als 30 milliarden euro
beschlossen
umgesetzt
es handelt sich hierbei um reiche
entlastungsmaßnahmen die zum teil auch
noch gar nicht wirken können weil sie
erst in einigen wochen dank in die
umsetzung gehen ich zum beispiel der
bereich der steuerfreibeträge oder auch
der bereich der heizkostenzuschüsse um
nur zwei beispiele zu nennen aus diesem
entlastungspaket werden aber eigentlich
immer nur zwei maßnahmen diskutiert in
der öffentlichkeit nämlich dass neun
euro ticket und zum anderen der tank
rabatt beim neuen euro ticket meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren kann man
sagen das ist ein voller erfolg das
trägt bei vielen menschen dazu bei die
zum beispiel täglich zur arbeit pendeln
müssen und sonst teure monatsfahrkarten
kaufen müssen dass sie deutlich
entlastet werden momentan
beim tank rabatt dagegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren merken wir
deutlich wie schwierig es ist dass die
gute beabsichtigte steuersenkungen denn
das ist auch beim tanken krabat ja eine
steuersenkung auch tatsächlich bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ankommt das
gleiche kann uns übrigens auch bei einer
mehrwertsteuer senkung für
grundnahrungsmittel passieren wer meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren
garantiert uns denn dass das land rot
was momentan vier euro kostet zukünftig
mit einer mehrwertsteuersenkung dann
drei euro 74 kostet vielleicht noch beim
bäcker um die ecke weil der ehrlich auch
sein entsprechenden vorteil weitergibt
an die kunden aber im supermarktregal
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir können doch relativ sicher sein dass
dort auch handelsketten genau diese
preisspanne nicht weitergeben an die
kundinnen und kunden
angesichts dieser preissteigerung in
deutschland hat der
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil aber
auch schon auf die grenzen staatlicher
eingriffsmöglichkeiten hingewiesen der
staat kann nicht alles für alle
ausgleichen hat er deutlich gemacht und
meine damen und herren ich denke wir
müssen auch deutlich machen wo die
grenzen der finanzierbarkeit sind aber
sie können sich sicher sein dass diese
bundesregierung und die sie tragenden
fraktionen intensiv darüber beraten
werden welche weiteren möglichkeiten wir
im kampf gegen die preissteigerungen in
den kommenden wochen neben bereits schon
gefassten beschlüssen zum
entlastungspaket möglicherweise auch
noch umsetzen können eines ist aber auch
klar wir müssen nicht die menschen
entlasten die ein sehr hohes einkommen
haben denn die spielräume des haushaltes
sind da eindeutig begrenzt das wäre aber
bei einer mehrwertsteuersenkung genau
der fall denn da entlasten wir auch die
menschen mit hohem einkommen und das
wäre nicht zielgerichtet
wir sind dabei zu sondieren wie man
gezielt menschen mit unteren und
mittleren einkommen entlasten kann
anders ausgedrückt hat es auch wieder
hubertus heil wir müssen die folgen der
preisentwicklung gezielt für die
menschen abfedern für die sie eine
wirklich existenzielle bedrohung ist das
ist das wichtigste ziel und ich bin sehr
froh dass unser bundeskanzler olaf
scholz anfang juli zu einer
konzertierten aktion eingeladen hat um
mit gewerkschaften arbeitgeberverbänden
und politik darüber zu beraten wie man
konkrete verabredung entwickeln kann was
die jeweiligen partner dazu beitragen
können auf diese preisentwicklung
einfluss zu nehmen auf diesen treffen zu
einer konzertierten aktion soll
gemeinsam geeignete maßnahmen gesprochen
werden wir wissen nicht wie lange diese
inflation meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren tatsächlich auch noch anhalten
wird aber wir hoffen natürlich dass die
preissteigerung wieder in ein von der
ezb als normalmaß also rund zwei prozent
in etwa preissteigerung sich entwickeln
werden eins aber wird bleiben
da die preise für die energie weiterhin
auf einem niveau bleiben müssen wir
darüber nachdenken wie wir den mit
kollegen einen einfachen einkommen
entlasten können vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
es ist immer gut weil es jetzt bei
kollegen und kolleginnen so war dass sie
doch die redezeit etwas ausgedehnt haben
daran zu denken was heute nacht passiert
also bei denen die dann hier noch sitzen
werden ich weiß nicht ob sie das denn
sein
aber das nicht an sie konkret sondern
wirklich an einige ich habe aber noch
eine sozusagen altlast hier übernommen
von max hatte das protokoll angefordert
herbrand es hat vorhin in einer debatte
von einem politisch gleichgeschalteten
block der schon länger hier sitzen
geredet ich erteile ihnen wegen
bewussten andocken an die dunkelsten
seiten der deutschen geschichte die
einem demokratischen parlament unwürdig
sind dafür einen ordnungsruf und
gebe das wort die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin katrin
göring-eckardt hat hier dirk brandes von
der afg einen ordnungsruf erteilt
sebastian bremen spricht als nächstes
für die unionsfraktion
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
in ganz deutschland entwickelt sich die
inflation zu einem der zentralen
herausforderungen und zwar für alle am
markt beteiligten auch dass die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher sind
aber übrigens auch der deutsche
mittelstand und die
inflationsentwicklung in diesem jahr ist
erschreckend 5,1 prozent im februar 7 3
prozent im märz 4 prozent im april und 7
die höchste inflation der kollege
künstlers gesagt seit der ölkrise 1973
74 in unserem land die energiepreise
sind 38 prozent gestiegen und die
lebensmittelpreise
11,1 prozent und viele menschen können
sich das normale leben nicht mehr
leisten und haben angst vor abstieg und
wohlstandsverlust und deswegen wie
kollege und kollegen der
regierungsparteien wir brauchen eine
wirksame initiative gegen inflation und
kein stückwerk so wie sie das machen und
wie sieht es derzeit praktizieren denn
ihre maßnahmen kommen bei der
bevölkerung nicht an liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und wir können was tun wir
können etwas tun aber sie müssen es halt
angehen liebe frau kollegin beck wenn
sie sagen die situation ist so sie haben
es in der hand machen sie es und nehmen
sie es an als regierung und bringen sie
es voran es braucht ein sinnvolles aber
auch ideologiefrei ist ein sinnvolles
und ideologiefrei ist konzept und wir
haben hier einige maßnahmen schon
vorgestellt die sie immer wieder bei
jeder debatte abgelehnt haben erstens
auf nationaler ebene müssen wir dringend
zu einem ausgeglichenen haushalt ohne
schulden sofort zurückkehren was sie
machen diese derzeitige rekordschulden
politik mit 300 milliarden schulden ist
erschreckend es sind mehr schulden als
in der deutschen einheit aufgenommen
werden bei diesem wichtigen projekt die
linken fordern ja sogar
weitere schulden in den nächsten jahren
zu machen lieber kollege görke auf
europäischer ebene zweitens muss die
europäische zentralbank die
niedrigzinspolitik und die anleihenkäufe
umgehend stoppen die diskussion jetzt um
weitere anleihenkäufe sind falsch sie
fordern allerdings anteil im parlament
sogar eine vergemeinschaftung von
schulden dazu gehört aber auch drittens
eine steuersenkung auf energieprodukte
auf das europäische mindestmaß tun sie
nicht bei der stromsteuer könnten sie
deutlich reduzieren wir haben beantragt
sie haben es abgelehnt
während sie hartz4 sanktionen abschaffen
belasten sie diejenigen die jeden tag
zur arbeit fahren der kollege künstler
hat es ja gesagt bei der
entfernungspauschale müssten wir
dringend eine erhöhung ab dem ersten
kilometer vornehmen wir werden das
beantragen und wahrscheinlich werden sie
es auch wieder ablehnen und beim energie
geld weil sie es vorhin gesagt seine
frau kollegin beck sie haben es munter
verteilt aber bei denjenigen die es
brauchen der minister bekommt aber der
student bekommt nicht der rentner
bekommt es nicht und familien mit
elterngeldbezug also mit kleinen kindern
bekommen es auch nicht dass während
diejenigen die es brauchen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und ein sechster punkt und da sollten
die kollegen und kolleginnen
insbesondere der grünen ihre
ideologische brille ablegen
sie wissen dass die energiepreise
steigen und könnten aber eine
preisstabilität erreichen wenn sie die
kernkraftwerke die laufzeiten verlängern
würden aber sie tun es nicht und
deswegen müssen sie uns erklären co2 ist
ihnen anscheinend in der diskussion egal
sie hätten es in der hand sie zu uns
aber aus ideologischen gründen nicht und
liebe kolleginnen kollegen im bereich
der steuern müssen wir die kalte
progression abschaffen erwarten sie auch
geschwinde ein bisschen ab die kleinen
und mittleren einkommen werde neben
nicht entlastet sondern durch die
inflation sogar weiter belastet durch
die jetzige bundesregierung
und wir haben ja das in der letzten
periode ausgiebig mit den kollegen der
spd diskutiert da haben sie schon
abgelehnt es braucht eine modernisierung
der unternehmensbesteuerung weil nur mit
wachstum kommen wir aus der krise und
den wir jetzt an die reden hört von roth
von rot und von grün die dann sagen wir
brauchen eine über gewinnsteuern dann
heißt es ja die inflation noch weiter an
und belastet noch mehr den mittelstand
liebe kolleginnen kollegen das in
falsche massnahmen die sie hier
vorschlagen und wir brauchen übrigens
auch eine preisgleitklausel bei
öffentlichen investitionen weil die
unternehmer derzeit überhaupt keine
öffentlichen investitionen machen weil
es ein riesen kostenrisiko ist für die
unternehmer auch das müssen wir zu und
natürlich müssen wir auch über die
entwicklung der lebensmittelpreise bei
grundnahrungsmitteln sprechen um die
stabil zu halten
weil sie haben richtigerweise des jahres
bei spiel gebracht wenn man ein konto
per butter verdoppelt verdoppelt sich
auch die mehrwertsteuereinnahmen beim
deutschen staat und deswegen müssen wir
das was der staat mehr aus mehr einnimmt
auch wieder an die bürgerinnen und
bürger zurückgeben was aber nicht
dazugehört und das ist der fehler in
ihrem antrag ist dass man gleichzeitig
dann eine preis überwachungsstelle und
unglaubliche bürokratie im staat wieder
einführen und vielleicht kommt es ja
dann wirklich dazu dass man am schluss
die preise vor gibt die große stärke der
sozialen marktwirtschaft ist eben dass
sich die preise dezentral bilden und
nicht von einem amt vorgegeben werden
deswegen können wir im antrag auch nicht
folgen liebe kolleginnen kollegen also
es ist die oberste aufgabe der
bundesregierung dafür zu sorgen dass die
menschen in unserem land nicht ärmer
werden
umverteilung schafft keinen wohlstand
liebe kolleginnen kollegen sie haben es
in der hand maßnahmen anzugehen es gibt
ein bündel von maßnahmen die
nachweislich inflation senken sie müssen
es aber einfach tun nur sonntagsreden zu
machen oder im bundesfinanzministerium
der lindner ist jetzt gegangen bei der
wichtigen debatte aber ein papier
vorzulegen und genau das gegenteil zu
machen von dem was er vorliegt im
bundesfinanzministerium in der
tatsächlichen politik ist eben auch
dieses gesicht der bundesregierung sie
tun wesentlich zu wenig sie treiben die
inflation und sie machen die menschen in
unserem land ärmer vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
sebastian bremen war das und sie haben
gesehen dass wir nicht mehr nach brüssel
schauen denn das treffen ist anscheinend
ohne fortschritte beendet die
pressekonferenz wurde abgesagt wir
erwarten aber in etwa 20 minuten
immerhin ein statement von bundeskanzler
olaf scholz auch das würden wir ihn dann
natürlich zeigen jetzt spricht renate
künast für bündnis 90 die grünen
die anderen sind alle ideologen die nun
mal lieblich und dann behauptet die
studentinnen und studenten würden keine
energiepreis pauschale bekommen 65 75
prozent der studenten und studenten
haben einen mini job zu bekommen deshalb
eine energie
so viel zu dem stil
ich habe einen antrag der linken sagen
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich beschäftige
mich mit dem thema ernährung preise mehr
in allem schon viele jahre jetzt muss
ich noch mal leider ganz verhalten sagen
ein bisschen populistisch ist der antrag
schon so kurz wie populistisch ja zwei
kleine forderungen und am ende möchte
ich sagen dann doch ein bisschen
unterkomplex warum weil wir haben es
doch mit zwei punkten zu tun wir haben
es mit zwei punkten zu tun das sind
vorschläge natürlich ihr können
ja ich bitte danke diese mache ich
wir haben es mit
wir haben es mit doch mit folgendem zu
tun der eine punkt ist die wehr zwei
aufgaben vor uns der eine punkt ist er
dass wir in der akuten situation was sie
ja eigentlich auch wo er den ärmsten der
armen den ärmeren finanziell helfen und
ich glaube vor so und so viele minuten
hat hier auch mal von uns in der anderen
debatte andreas dreitz geredet der auch
dann sehr genau und andere auch
vorgerechnet hat was die entlastungs
pakete von uns bringen 30 milliarden
euro es gab auch rechnung wenn einmal
alles einbezieht kommen wir teilweise
auf eine entlastung bis zu 100 prozent
und das alles wird in den nächsten tagen
wirken zb zum ersten juli meine das ist
der wichtige punkt und der kern dabei
ist dass man es zielgenau macht man muss
sich bei den maßnahmen auch überlegen
wie es denn bei den ärmeren bei den
beziehern von sozialleistungen bei den
geringeren einkommen ankommt meine damen
und herren deshalb ist ist neun euro
ticket auch wenn es nur drei monate gilt
ist eine erhöhte grundsicherung das sind
die punkte damit das zielgenau ankommt
und nicht mit einer gießkanne über das
problem gehen zweiter punkt
bin ich jetzt nicht diejenigen die da
jetzt endlich mal zur stellung nimmt zu
dem thema ernährung obst gemüse sie
sagen immer grundnahrungsmittel was noch
mehr als ich will das aufnehmen ich will
ihnen sagen wenn sie anfangen darüber zu
reden dass die ärmsten der armen sich
doch mehr von der gesunden ernährung
obst und gemüse leisten können müssen
was wir schon lange fordern ja dann
müssen sie sich aber auch genauer
angucken welche maßnahme wirkt wie ich
habe schon lange darüber nachgedacht
auch viele bei uns über die
mehrwertsteuersenkung für gemüse obst
hülsenfrüchte die würde wenn man sie so
ein eng zwei milliarden euro kosten
natürlich nicht hundertprozentig ab
sicher war dass sie auch umgesetzt
obwohl 2020 wurde das mal umgesetzt und
umgelegt und kam den kunden zu passt das
eu-recht erlaubt dass der
wissenschaftliche beirat des
agrarministeriums hat 2020 auch das
gefordert und hat einmal gerechnet und
gesagt wenn man zwei prozentpunkte
runtergehen würde das heißen dass ein
prozent nachfragesteigerung wäre wenn
wir das weiter rechnen sieben prozent
ganz wegzunehmen würde dann zu 3,5
prozent nachfragesteigerung führen das
sind 13 gramm mehr heißt 3 179 gramm
obst und gemüse würde gegessen das ist
aber nur ein drittel der verzehrs
empfehlung der deutschen gesellschaft
für ernährung ich habe mir die rechen
übung gemacht meine damen und herren so
damit merken wir dann eisen diese
maßnahme gar nicht aus dass diese
maßnahme gar nicht ausreichen würde ich
will jetzt aber nicht veralbern sondern
ich will ihnen sagen dass akut für die
ärmsten der armen wir auf dem weg sind
und was tun für die frage was
grundsätzlich zu tun ist braucht es mehr
als diese mehrwertsteuerdebatte meine
damen und herren ernährungsbedingte
erkrankungen ist es sind auch ein armuts
armut in der ernährung thema 35
milliarden euro 35 milliarden euro pro
jahr werden ausgegeben in deutschland
für ernährungsbedingte erkrankungen und
deshalb brauchen wir ein ganzes paket
wir wissen über die steuern diskutieren
gemeinschaftsverpflegung ich würde mir
wünschen dass die bundesländer gerne
auch thüringen die kinderernährung
kostenlos machen und eine gute ernährung
bieten wir müssen an kinder gerichtete
werbung für zucker bauten ein denn wir
müssen subventionen verteilt und ich bin
froh das ist mein letzter punkt frau
präsidentin dass die verbraucherminister
konferenz
und alt ist auch als aufgabe gegeben hat
gesagt hat dass sie froh ist dass die
bundesregierung eine umfassende
ernährungsstrategien bis nächstes jahr
erarbeiten will unter ziffer 49
beschluss arbeit kölner zielgenau
mittlere und kleinere einkommen
entlasten und
das kann nicht sein ich kann ihnen genau
wie kommen sie hier aufgeschrieben ich
kann ihnen genau zeigen weil dem wann
hier ermahnt worden ist und ich bin bei
frau künast immer besonders genau weil
wird schon länger kennt
jetzt aber
das weiß ich
jetzt aber hat der kollege robert fall
das wort für die art die fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren
der antrag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin der antrag
der linken für die aussetzung der
mehrwertsteuer auf grundnahrungsmittel
ist meines erachtens im grundsatz
richtig
denn er wiederholt auch eine forderung
der afd die schon am 6 april in diesen
bundestag eingebracht worden ist und mit
der änderung der eu
mehrwertsteuerrichtlinie vom fünften
april wäre die aussetzung der
mehrwertsteuer auf grundnahrungsmittel
schon damals rechtlich einwandfrei
umsetzbar gewesen
da man mit sachargumenten bei der ampel
koalition nichts durchbringen kann ist
unser damaliger antrag nicht angenommen
wurden das wird auch ihnen bevorstehen
ich muss aber sagen dieser antrag ist
zielgenau weil diese ganzen argumente
nur scheinargumente sind um zu wissen
welche zielgruppen sie erreichen gehen
sie bitte einfach mal in die supermärkte
in ihrer region und dann schauen sie mal
wie viele leute mittlerweile mit dem
cent rechnen und wie viel ware wieder
zurück gebracht wird weil man gerade ein
paar euro über dem liegt was man von zu
hause mitbringen konnte wenn sie das
nicht tun dann machen sie sich schuldig
über dinge zu reden hier und zu sprechen
die gar nicht die sie nicht verfolgen
die galoppierende inflation und die
preissteigerung in sämtlichen
lebensbereichen gab es schon vor dem
ukrainer konflikt und die ursachen
bestehen vor allem in der
exorbitanten schulen macher
schuldenmacherei dieser koalition die
jetzt regiert und der vorgänger
koalition mit der druckerpresse geld ins
in die welt zu setzen der
ezb nullzinspolitik dass die zweite
hauptursache und die ständig steigende
geldmenge inflation zur rettung der
südlichen eu pleitestaaten die ständig
am tropf der eu hängt seit 20 20 hat die
ezb die geldmenge um über 20 prozent
erweitert und immer weitere anleihen
verkäufe getätigt und damit vieles mit
geld geflutet und am endergebnis haben
wir jetzt eine galoppierende inflation
bekommen dazu kommen die probleme durch
den corona lockdown die globalen
lieferketten wurden vielfach zerstört
und das weißt du was man unbedingt
erwähnen muss auch in richtung der
grünen es geht einfach nicht wir haben
wahrscheinlich die dümmste
energiepolitik in der ganzen welt im
alleingang in deutschland was uns die
höchsten strompreise weltweit beschert
hat und sie stellen sich hier groß hin
wir wollen aus russland kein billiges
gas kaufen sie wollen teures gas aus den
usa importieren wunderbar die
abhängigkeit ist wieder da und von den
arabern dass der gleiche und das ende
vom lied ist der mensch kann nicht mehr
sein auto finanzieren da kann das fahren
die mobilität nicht mehr finanziert und
dann schmeißen sie noch milliarden raus
in anderem zusammenhang dann müssen sie
nämlich auch bei den steuern wider was
machen usw weitere ursachen der
inflation ihre co2 steuer hat mein
kollege gottschalk schon neuer erläutert
wenn es nicht wissen glauben dann
schauen sie mal ein von dieter bähre das
ist die dümmste sanktionspolitik die wir
zurzeit betreiben das in russland der
rubel rollt was soll das denn diese
unter sanktioniert werden jetzt freuen
die sich über diese steigenden
energiepreise die sie selbst mit
herbeiführen
und die
energieversorgung in unserem land machen
sie immer knapper und zur
mangelwirtschaft kohle weg atom weg sie
gehen hier nicht ran an die wirkliche
notwendig maßnahmen ich komme damit zum
schluss zehn milliarden
indien gegeben worden die kaufen jetzt
das russische öl billig ein und
vertraulicher jetzt zu uns da hätten wir
im winter vielleicht auch kollege öl
haben vielen dank ich bedanke mich für
geschätzte aufmerksamkeit und sage ihnen
beschließen sie was sinnvoll ist und das
ist die senkung der lebensmittelpreise
vielen dank
robert fahle war das und es steht schon
eher bereit maximilian not horst für die
fdp fraktion und mitglied im
finanzausschuss
zurück aus moskau nach berlin sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich kann auch
im angesicht des antrages
beziehungsweise der anträge die vorlegen
nur wer dazu raten eine gewisse oder
mehr konsequenz im steuersystem an den
tag zu legen haben schon darüber
gesprochen das mehrwertsteuersystem da
kann man jeden experten fragen das ist
nicht konsequent und wir sollten das mal
grundsätzlich angehen ich wundere mich
aber schon über die eine oder andere
aussage die sowohl von union als auch
linkspartei kommt einerseits wird gesagt
die energie steuersenkung wie wir sie
beschlossen haben kommen nicht an die
union möchte dann die stromsteuer senken
die müsste genauso weitergegeben werden
und sie wollen die mehrwertsteuer senken
und könnten damit nach ihrer eigenen
argumentation den lebensmittelkonzern in
die hände spielen also doch bitte etwas
mehr ehrlichkeit vielleicht auch ifo
institut verlassen nämlich die energie
steuersenkung kommt an und dann können
wir auch mit mehr ernsthaftigkeit über
die anträge diskutieren diese hier
vorgelegt haben ich wundere mich auch
zweitens weil ich gut verstehen kann
dass man jetzt sagt na ja man sollte er
von den sieben auf null gehen zumindest
zeitweise ich finde steuersenkung als
liberaler prinzipiell immer gut aber
sie offenbar in ihren eigenen
eigentlichen willen immer wieder wenn
man ihren antrag genau liest und das
wurde auch schon von kolleginnen und
kollegen erwähnt sie wollen nämlich
nicht nur die mehrwertsteuer senken sie
war noch eine preis beobachtungsstelle
bedeutet im umkehrschluss
staatliche aufsicht über preise und das
bedeutet übrigens nicht nur
mehr sozialistische ader die dann im
staat stattfindet mehr aufsicht es
bedeutet auch mehr personal im
öffentlichen dienst ist bedeutet
mehrausgaben auch dass wieder ein
inflationstreiber und deswegen auf gar
keinen fall die antwort auf das was wir
machen können und müssen um den
steigenden lebensmittelpreisen
entgegenzuwirken ich bin deswegen
überzeugt ich bin deswegen überzeugt
dass das bisherige was wir gemacht haben
in bezug auf die entlastung die wir
vorgenommen haben und das auch mal in
richtung der unionsfraktion zu sagen
immer wieder wann kommen die wann kommen
die und die würden nicht ankommen einige
haben wir schon auf den weg gebracht
andere gelten erst mit der
steuererklärung wiederum andere wie die
energie pauschale kommen im september
also dann jetzt zu sagen die entlastung
die noch gar nicht wirken die würden
jetzt schon nicht ankommen ich glaube
das ergibt keinen sinn und damit liegen
sie die menschen auch ein stück weit an
weil es schlicht und ergreifend nicht
stimmt dass das ganze was wir
beschlossen haben schon auf den weg
gebracht ist und es muss erst mal wirken
können dann ich glaube das wäre
ehrlicher den menschen gegenüber
entsprechend bitte ich sie den weg den
wir eingeschlagen haben weiter zu
unterstützen weiterhin dafür zu sorgen
dass wir mehr konstanz in unser
steuersystem bringen gerne freue ich
mich über eine diskussion wie auch vom
kollegen künstler und bremen von den
kollegen künstler und bremen angekündigt
darüber wieder verbrauchssteuer verkehr
steuern konsequenter
sortieren und besseres ein besseres
system auf den weg bringt man kennt das
alles kaviar 7 prozent babywindeln 19
ich glaube da sind auch viele andere
fraktionen offen für und das wäre ein
richtiger weg und ein richtiger impuls
den wir aus ihrem schlechten antrag
gerne mitnehmen
das muss erwähnt werden genau war
wirklich genau auf den punkt
amazon hat das wort für die spd fraktion
es wird aber ausgesprochen ich über das
und freue mich sehr über die korrektur
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren wir haben bereits
mehrfach ihren plänen sowohl über die
mehrwertsteuer als auch über die
inflation gesprochen zuletzt heute
vormittag freut mich sehr dass wir diese
diskussion weiterführen können denn die
steigenden lebenspralle die wir gerade
sehen
machen das eigentlich für unsere
politikerinnen politiker zur aufgabe das
ist unsere oberste priorität sein muss
die menschen zu entlasten und deswegen
ist es auch richtig dass wir heute
erneut darüber diskutieren aber liebe
kolleginnen kollegen bei den vielen
verschiedenen maßnahmen die wir auch
kontrovers diskutieren müssen wir schon
unterscheiden wir müssen einmal
unterscheiden zwischen maßnahmen die
jetzt brauchen die wir sofort brauchen
um bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten
auf der einen seite und andere
strukturelle maßnahmen die wir brauchen
um die inflation zu bekämpfen und beim
ersteren ist es ja nicht so dass wir als
ampelkoalition bis jetzt nicht geliefert
hätten wir haben umfangreiche
leistungspakete verabschiedet die vor
allem bürgerinnen und bürger mit
niedrigen und mittleren einkommen
gezielt erreichen werden angesichts von
über 16 millionen verkauften neuen euro
tickets und dazu kommen noch über zehn
millionen menschen mit bestehenden abos
die sich auch solche tickets gekauft
haben kann man sagen dass allein das
neun euro ticket eine hervorragende
maßnahme war und dass es bei allen
menschen ankommt und jetzt bereits schon
wird
weitere maßnahmen sind die abschaffung
der eeg umlage der erhöhte
grundfreibetrag die der
heizkostenzuschuss meine kolleginnen
kollegen haben das vorhin schon erwähnt
diese maßnahmen sind die zieht ja wir
wissen es gibt den tank rabatt darüber
wird ja auch sehr kontrovers diskutiert
das kommt nicht an das muss man auch
selbstkritisch wir sagen aber die
entlassungs pakete die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben sind ja auch mehr als nur
der tank rabatt und diese maßnahmen
werden gezielt wirken und die wellen die
menschen erreichen genau die dies auch
brauchen
aber wenn es jetzt darum geht
strukturell die inflation zu bekämpfen
wissen ja dass die europäische
zentralbank auch hier in der
verantwortung ist und sie wird seinen
teil dazu tun das wissen wir aber auch
wir als parlament können einen beitrag
dazu leisten um aber die inflation
strukturell zu bekämpfen müssen wir auch
verstehen woher die ursachen kommen die
aktuelle inflation ist nicht eine
inflation wie aus dem wirtschafts
lehrbuch es geht nicht um eine
weitflächige überhitzte wirtschaft sie
sozusagen durch das erhöhen der zinsen
und die reduktion der geldmenge so
einfach wieder eingeschränkt werden kann
bei der inflation gibt es vor allem zwei
ursachen
das ist vor allem der schock auf die
energiepreise durch den russischen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine
und das ist aber auch die lieferengpässe
die unterbrochenen lieferketten die wir
als folge der kobik pandemie sehen und
trotzten auch als folgen des russischen
angriffskrieg beides führt dazu dass die
preise für viele produkte ansteigen auf
der einen seite für unternehmen in der
produktion auch bei den lebensmitteln
aber auch für verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher in den supermärkten an der
tankstelle daher ist es also hilfreich
jetzt nicht konsum und investitionen
bremsen zu wollen denn sie sind auch in
den letzten wochen gestiegen nicht
gestiegen im gegenteil im letzten monat
beobachten wir einen rückgang des
konsums und deswegen kann das nicht die
lösung sein um die inflation zu
bekämpfen vielmehr brauchen wir
strukturelle maßnahmen um die speziellen
ursachen der inflation zu bekämpfen und
die wirtschaft zu unterstützen
um den schock auf die energie preise zu
reduzieren müssen wir unsere
abhängigkeit von russischen und fossilen
rohstoffen beseitigen wir müssen massiv
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
massiv vorantreiben das haben wir uns
als ampel koalition vorgenommen und das
wenn wir auch tun
zweitens
zweitens braucht es aber auch maßnahmen
um dauerhaft die engpässe zu beseitigen
dazu gehört zum beispiel dass die unsere
lieferketten diversifizieren müssen dazu
gehört dass wir mehr in infrastruktur
investieren müssen dazu gehört aber auch
dass die maßnahmen brauchen zur
gewinnung von fachkräften liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die als
ampelkoalition haben wir einen ganz
klaren fokus sofort die menschen
unterstützen insbesondere kleinen und
mittleren einkommen aber aber auch die
strukturellen benötigten maßnahmen die
auf den weg zu bringen um die inflation
zu bekämpfen
vielen dank
arm und so war es für die spd-fraktion
er ist mitglied im finanzausschuss wie
auch der nächste redner hermann josef
tebroke aus der unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren die auf den
rängen und an den übertragungs geräten
ganz offensichtlich sind wir uns hier
weitestgehend zumindest in drei punkten
einig zum einen wir erkennen eine
allgemeine inflation auf rekordniveau
ich würde gerne der stelle gerne
ergänzen das besonders kritisch der sehr
kurzfristige steile anstieg der
inflation ist weil dadurch
anpassungsmaßnahmen reader sind wir sind
uns zweitens einig dass von der
inflation unternehmen und private
haushalte unterschiedlich einige
heftigst betroffen sind und wir sind uns
offensichtlich drittens einig dass
schnell etwas unternommen werden muss
sagten sie auch herr görg und ob sie
frau weg ausgeführt allerdings müssten
diese maßnahmen gezielt sein sie müssen
wirksam sein und sie sollten abgestimmt
sein in einem zusammenhängenden konzept
und so habe ich auch ihren beitrag
herzhorn gerade verstanden dass wir
etwas umfassender uns gedanken machen
müssen wie wir der inflation begegnet
das heißt wir müssen mindestens
unterscheiden maßnahmen zur abmilderung
der akuten folgen von inflation für
einzelne bürgerinnen und bürger und für
unternehmen und auf der anderen seite
maßnahmen die die gründe die ursachen
bekämpfen die dann zur inflation führen
in deutschland befindet sehr wichtige
unterscheidung in deutschland sind es
weniger die nachholeffekte die
erwarteten nachholeffekte im anschluss
an die korona fand nie sondern sind
angebots schocks die uns erreicht haben
und wenn wir auf diese reagieren wollen
dann müssen wir auch mit angebotspolitik
tendenziell antworten das wäre auch
unser forscher unser vorschlag als union
worüber wir uns aber klar sein müssen
meine damen und herren das günstige
energie quellen internationale
wirtschaftsbeziehungen und
arbeitsteilung uns lange jahre wohlstand
ermöglicht haben dass wir aber wenig
diversifiziert und damit abhängig waren
und das wird uns jetzt auf die füße
stellen fest lieferengpässe wir stellen
fest preissteigerungen ja und ich
befürchte dass wir auch feststellen
werden den nächsten monaten eine sehr
angespannte allgemeine wirtschaftliche
situation auf die wir uns vorbereiten
müssen was können wir gegen inflation
ton einige punkte sind angesprochen
worden was können wir grundsätzlich
gegen inflation tun etwa im bereich der
handels energie und wirtschaftspolitik
da möchte ich nur kurz verweisen auf die
vielen vorschläge die wir seitens der
union schon gemacht haben ich kann nach
wie vor nicht erkennen warum die nicht
uns um neue handelsbeziehungen bemühen
etwa durch den abschluss eines vertrags
mit kanada ich kann nicht verstehen
warum wir zum zweiten nicht mehr
engagement an den tag legen um energie
aus anderen fällen auch zu beschaffen
und noch mehr hier an energie zu
generieren wie wir das jüngst in unseren
antrag auch aufgezeigt haben wie das
gehen könnte und drittens ich glaube es
ist wichtig angebots politisch die
rahmenbedingungen für unternehmen und
handeln zu verbessern das heißt
bürokratieabbau beschlagen beschleunigte
genehmigungsverfahren
unternehmensgründungen zu fördern
wettbewerbsfähiges
unternehmenssteuerrecht zu realisieren
dazu haben wir viele vorschläge gemacht
sind beiträge angebots politisch die
rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern
um diese engpässe aufzuheben dafür
brauchen wir mehr unterstützung das
erwarten wir eigentlich von der ampel
und da erkennen wir zu wenig engagement
im bereich der fiskalpolitik
sollten wir uns etwas
zurückhaltung bemühen ausgaben des
staates zur beförderung der konjunktur
können aber auch drei steigern wirken
was wir für richtig und wichtig halten
und auch die kollegen haben es gerade
noch einmal gefordert ist endlich eine
verlässliche und konsequente anpassung
des einkommensteuertarifs da warten wir
immer noch auf endliche auf handeln
ampeln und
auch geldpolitische möglichkeiten möchte
ich an dieser stelle nur ganz kurz
hinweisen herz waren sie hatten einige
anmerkungen dazu gemacht wir wissen alle
die zinsen zu erhöhen könnte die
sparneigung befördern könnte den
außenwert des euro steigern das wären zu
wünschen aber wir wissen auch um die
risiken in den büchern der kreditgeber
und wir wissen auch um die nachteiligen
effekte bei der investitionsbereitschaft
wir ärgern uns das haben wir als union
wiederholt beklagt über die geldpolitik
der ezb der letzten jahre sie hat sich
in eine situation hinein manövriert
jetzt nicht mehr effizient handeln zu
können die einzige möglichkeit ist
langsam in kalkulierbaren schritten die
zinsen zu erhöhen damit geld politik
endlich wieder berechenbar unglaubwürdig
wird das dämmt auch die investitions
erwartung dass ist das projekt das ist
die maßnahme das ist eine politik die
wir von der ezb dringen einfordern
meine damen und herren und dann bin ich
bei dem dritten punkt wie können wir den
akuten belastungen der haushalte und
auch der unternehmen begegnen habe zwei
vorschläge vorlegen auf die schon einen
ausführlich eingegangen worden ist aber
der vorschlag der afg in ihrem antrag
vom 16 dritten alleine titel
steuersenkungen als reaktion auf die
inflation der es erkennen wie geht es
gar nicht um ursachenanalyse sondern
irgendwie nur auf irgendein projekt eine
antwort wir haben diskutiert was es mit
den zeitraum mit der zielgruppe was ist
mit einem finanzierungsvorschlag was
bleibt
eine unterstützenswerte motivation aber
ansonsten auch nichts deswegen lehnen
wir diesen antrag ab der vorschlag der
linken auch darauf ist bereits
eingegangen worden zur akuten milderung
der auswirkungen der inflation über die
definition der grundnahrungsmittel
werden wir streiten müssen ich freue
mich dass auch die kollegen schon
signalisiert haben dass sie das
umsatzsteuerrecht noch mal auf den kopf
stellen wollen die wirkung haben wir
diskutiert meine damen und herren aber
das was ich überhaupt nicht verstehen
kann und wir haben einige vorderräder
insbesondere künstler darauf hingewiesen
dass gerade die linke einen solchen
antrag stellt der offensichtlich am ende
gerade den nicht so sehr betroffenen
weniger hilfe der gerichte infrage
stellen
das ist eine gute idee aber zu spät
angesichts ihrer redezeit was herr gott
ja nicht wissen konnte insofern ich sehe
jetzt einfach bitten vielleicht zu ahnen
was er fragen will und da auch noch die
antwort zu geben und dann ist die
redezeit gänzlich um und überschritten
also ich habe sie so verstanden
das werde ich auch machen jürgen freuen
uns auf die debatte ihres antrags im
ausschuss da wären wir das vertiefen
aber sie können an den wenigen bemerkten
schon erkennen wenn wir inflation
wirksam und entschlossen begegnen wollen
dann müssen wir die ursachen bekämpfen
und die akuten belastung abmildern und
zwar in einem abgestimmten konzept und
dazu leisten der beitrag und leistet der
antrag der linken kein sophienstift und
beitragen werden deswegen vermutlich
haben vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
und freunden beraten
[Applaus]
die checks ist jetzt der nächste retten
redner für die fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen sieht janitschek ist die
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr dr die brücke ich fand
ihren beitrag
wohltuend differenziert dann habe ich
aber nachgeschaut und gesehen dass sie
aus den reihen der cdu csu fraktion
kommen wir hatten ja heute früh schon
eine diskussion zum thema inflation und
bekämpfung und dort hatte ich ganz
andere töne gehört nämlich dass wir
einen umfragen von umfangreichen
nachfrage stimmen brauchen würden um die
inflation zu bekämpfen und weniger den
angebotsschock wir uns ja gibt es zu
betonen also ich gratuliere ihnen zu
ihren aussagen aber wünsche auch ihrer
fraktion dass da ein bisschen mehr von
ihrer expertise in die fraktion bei
ihnen rein kommt
ja die vielfalt bilden sie
abwehrkünstler das mag schon sein aber
sie müssen sich auch mal entscheiden was
sie wollen sie können ja nicht auf der
einen seite sagen sie bekämpfen die
inflation in dem sie breiten schichten
der gesellschaft jetzt kaufkraft geben
ich glaube wenn sie ein bisschen
ökonomischer theorie unterwegs sind
wissen sie dass das die inflation januar
einst also müssen wir zielgerichtet
entlasten und da ist natürlich angst zum
leben zu sagen dass gerade in einem
solchen bereich wie die linke das jetzt
in ihrem antrag vorgeschlagen hat
entlastungen vorkommen könnten trotzdem
glaube ich ist die sinnvolle position zu
sagen grad aus der erfahrung der
mehrwertsteuer debatten der letzten
jahre dass wir eine umfassende ordnung
brauchen und nicht einzelne bereiche uns
raus nehmen um dort dann entlastung
herbei zu führen dass das natürlich auch
gesundheitliche ernährungspolitische
implikationen hat das will ich gar nicht
klein reden auch in unserer fraktion
wird er intensiv darüber diskutiert also
sie haben das schon auch einen punkt
getroffen der uns sehr bewegt aber am
ende müssen wir doch in dem
entlastungspaket uns mal genau anschauen
wo ist eigentlich die inflation so ich
glaub kollegin beck hat das vorhin schon
gesagt in der zeit gab es auch eine gute
übersicht dazu also der großteil des der
acht prozent ist
energiepreissteigerungen ist kraftstoffe
ist im bereich wohnen das ist dann die
weitergabe über die lebensmittel das ist
dann auch in kultur im
gastronomiebereich also was kann man in
einer solchen situation tun auf der
einen seite lehnt angebotsschock kann
man ja kurzfristig nicht ausgleichen
stück weit macht dass die ezb in dem sie
sagt sie dämpft sozusagen die wirkungen
aber letztlich kann der angebotsschock
letztlich nur ausgeglichen werden indem
es wieder mehr angebot gibt so und das
ist kurzfristig nicht etwas was wir
leisten können dann müssen wir auch
ehrlich sein also müssen wir dort
entlasten wo es sinnvoll ist und das
haben wir glaube ich gut getan jetzt mit
unseren ersten 30 milliarden die wir auf
den weg gebracht haben aber wir müssen
auch immer im blick behalten dass die
maßnahmen dazu beitragen müssen die
inflation auch zu bekämpfen und nicht
auszuweiten sollen das ist glaube ich
eine diskussion die ganz wichtig ist
auch schwierig ist denn am ende bringt
uns ja nichts wenn wir eine nachfrage
explosionen haben in bestimmten
bereichen und dann gestiegene preise
abschließend möchte ich sagen ich freue
mich dass wir alle gemeinsam um den
richtigen weg ringen das ist auch
absolut notwendig dass wir das tun und
heute ist der tag der gaststube das
heißt ein weiterer verschlechterung der
situation ist erst einmal eingetreten
das heißt wir werden sicherlich nicht
das letzte mal darüber sprechen sondern
auch im kommenden winter noch mal genau
gucken müssen wo können wir entlasten
und das thema gerade gas heizungskosten
und diesem bereich bei vielen ruf das
besorgnis hervor das kann ich
nachvollziehen das heißt wir sind nicht
am ende der diskussion aber es ist
notwendig dass wir uns differenziert und
zielgerichtet damit auseinandersetzen
vielen dank
ingo buck
angebot jetzt der nächste redner für die
fdp fraktion
auch präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
der vorliegende antrag mehrwertsteuer
auf grundnahrungsmittel aussetzen so
einkommensschwache haushalte
unterstützen
sie argumentieren damit dass kleine und
mittlere einkommensbezieher einen
größeren teil ihres einkommens für
nahrungsmittel ausgeben als
spitzenverdiener
allerdings haben sich außer acht
gelassen dass in deutschland die
ausgaben für grundnahrungsmittel
prozentual am verfügbaren einkommen gar
nicht so hoch sind
die einspareffekte für den einzelnen
verbraucher seien nun reich oder arm
wird nicht signifikant im geldbeutel der
menschen spürbar sein
diese art von sozialpolitik mit der
gießkanne funktioniert nicht weil sie
nicht zielsicher auf die betreffenden
personen gruppen ausgerichtet ist
eine mehrwertsteuersenkung für grund-
mittel-
grundnahrungsmittel vertreten diese
fallen ihre wirkung vielmehr sollte sie
tatsächlich eine zielgenaue entlastung
wie beispielsweise für eine
einkommensteuersenkung erfolgen eine
direkte subventionierung ist ebenfalls
kräftig mit
den entlastungs paketen 1 und 2 hat die
bundesregierung zielgerichtete maßnahmen
auf den weg gebracht um schnell und
unbürokratisch zu helfen
[Applaus]
die einmalzahlung von 200 euro für
sozialhilfeempfänger und der kinderbonus
in höhe von 100 euro stellen eine echte
entlastung für einkommensschwache
menschen
ich gebe zu bedenken mit dem aussetzen
der mehrwertsteuer werden auch
gutverdiener entlastet obwohl sie nicht
die zielgruppe für die steuerentlastung
sind
fakt ist durch eine solche maßnahme
gehen dem staat einnahmen in
milliardenhöhe verloren
angesichts der aktuellen angespannten
haushaltslage können wir es uns einfach
nicht leisten auf diese steuereinnahmen
verzichten
das eigentliche ziel einer entlastung
der geringverdiener wird verfehlt sehr
geehrte damen und herren unser
außenminister machte jüngst den
vorschlag die mehrwertsteuer für obst
gemüse pilze früchte abzuschaffen
entschuldigung der
landwirtschaftsminister sie haben recht
und
und damit einkommensschwache haushalte
zu entlasten
bei den hülsenfrüchten scheint ja eines
nicht bedacht zu haben wer mehr
hülsenfrüchte ist stößt mehr co2
im gleichen atemzug wird das argument
vorgebracht dass die menschen dann auch
mehr obst und gemüse kaufen und damit
einen anreiz erhalten sich gesünder zu
ernähren aber es hört sich für mich so
an als ob die mehrwertsteuerbefreiung
eine lenkungswirkung in richtung gesunde
ernährung übernehmen
sehen sie mir die kritik nahm aber für
mich ist das nichts anderes als klientel
politik und der steuerzahler zahlt die
zeche zum glück könnte sich dieser
vorschlag auch in der koalition nicht
durchsetzen
die beiden anträge
vielen dank
[Applaus]
am rand der redezeit deswegen konnte ich
nicht zulassen dass kann man immer ja
von dort wo man wünscht dazwischen
nachzufragen oder zuvor oder eine
intervention zu geben nicht sehen
deswegen rufe ich jetzt auf den kollegen
michael schrodi für die spd und michael
schuldig ist der finanzpolitische
sprecher der sozialdemokraten im
deutschen bundestag
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wenn ich heute zwei
debatten zum thema inflation
zusammenfassen und auch die reden und
mit ausnahme hat das kollegen t brücke
noch mal die ard wir reden und anträge
auch der cdu csu dann muss man
festhalten wie sich die cdu/csu
inflationsbekämpfung vorstellt
milliardenschwere steuersenkungen weiter
laufen lassen der atomkraft das ganze
und neue schulen oder steuersenkungen
also selbst die großen illusionskünstler
künstler warten auf die antwort darauf
wie friedlich und die märz das alles
zusammenbringen will sie warten
vergeblich auf diese antwort gibt es
nämlich nicht und das ist unseriös
darstellen zweitens was in der inflation
inflationär wird wird sind der anträge
zur mehrwertsteuersenkung es ist so ein
allheilmittel für alle möglichen
lenkungswirkung die frage ist hilft es
denn in dieser situation wirklich um
inflation zu dämpfen und zu bekämpfen
wichtig ist herr görg das die hersteller
regressiv wirkt
kleine mittlere einkommen
geben mehr für oder brauchen mehr ihres
haushaltseinkommens
bei der mehrwertsteuer durch die
mehrwertsteuer als es hohe einkommen
aufwenden das gilt dann auch für die
entlastung das ist so deswegen war ich
auch ein befürworter der
mehrwertsteuersenkung in der pandemie
als wir einen konjunkturellen impuls
setzen wolken und auch geschafft haben
in einem ganz anderen umfeld und
gleichzeitig hat es ebenso regressiv
auch gewirkt fand ich damals richtig
habe ich gefordert habe gemacht war auch
glaube ich ganz gut in dieser situation
ist es aber anders wenn wir uns das
anschauen erstes mal auf die
beschränkung der grundnahrungsmittel ist
glatt auch schon erwähnt worden wie viel
geben eigentlich menschen auch glatt
kleine einkommens für nahrungsmittel aus
es hat der ulrich schneider vom
paritätischen wohlfahrtsverband letztes
mal ganz großer ausgerechnet hat gesagt
155 euro im monat mit der steuersenkung
würden sie im monat 10 euro und laster
ist nur dass hülsenfrüchte beschränken
würde zwei euro im monat das ist nicht
die welt das ist ein kleiner beitrag
aber nicht das was wirklich gebraucht
die robertos halle 1 richtig gesagt
gestern zum thema mehrwertsteuersenkung
da profitieren eben auch höchste
einkommen davon wie das nicht brauchen
diese steuerentlastung gleichzeitig
haben wir mit einnahmen von 13 euro es
ist nicht zielgerichtet alleinigen 200
euro die wir als einmalzahlung für
grundsicherungsempfänger auf den weg
gebracht haben bedeuten 20 monate genau
diese steuersenkung die sie auf dem weg
ins ziel für die die es brauchen eine
gezieltere maßen mit dem wir bereits auf
mitgebracht haben deswegen gehen wir zum
einige mehrwertsteuer fällig auch
möchten sie denn herr kollege die
zwischenfragen zu lassen
bitteschön
kollege rudi vielen dank für die
möglichkeit die zwischen frage zu
stellen sie haben es ja gerade auf
röhrig schneider bezogen auf den
beziehen sich ja viele in meinem
diskussion und dann gibt es ja immer so
die frage welche forderungen auf wird
welche nimmt man nicht auf ich glaube
eine ganz wichtige forderung von ulrich
schneider ist vom parität die regelsätze
zu erhöhen und zwar auf mindestens 600
euro was halten sie denn von dieser
forderung und warum wollen sie die nicht
umsetzen
fehlt dafür die zwischenfrage wir werden
viele maßnahmen auf den weg bringen um
dieser inflation bei der
preissteigerungen entsprechen diese
freistellung abzudämpfen da gehören bei
der konzipierung
direktzahlungen mit dazu weil sie
schnell
helfen deswegen habe gesagt
mehrwertsteuer werden wir an der stelle
nicht unterstützen das große thema mit
den regelsätzen umgehen damit
beschäftigt sind auch diese koalition
wird das genauso diskutiert dass wir
sagen dass wir bei drei steigerungen
genauso oft den auf den weg bringen
müssen auch hier eine inflation setzte
anzupassen und essplatz entsprechen auch
er auf den weg zu bringen halte ich für
richtig in diese situation und die frage
über
inflationsdämpfend zu maßnahmen auf den
weg bringen können zu ihrem alltag der
steuersenkungen und da hat er wohl wie
schneidet kann sie als gag bezeichnet
und ist man aber wieder zu geben
deswegen wo das wollte ich ihnen
mitgeben und auch deswegen lehnen wird
ihren antrag und der abt
an der an der stelle muss man nur auf
fritz künstlern seine rede zu bekommen
weil er genau mit dieser argumentation
heute die mehrwertsteuersenkung
abgelehnt hat ja gesagt das nützt wenn
man die abzocken zahl nimmt mehr den
höheren einkommen ich gebe nummer eins
mit weil es warm ein zwischenruf gilt
das nicht auch für die kalte progression
also ich möchte nur mal darlegen dass
wir uns anschauen müssen welche
maßnahmen bringen wir auf den weg die
gezielt kleine und mittlere einkommen
tatsächlich entlasten und wir haben in
den letzten jahren immer die kalte
progression vollständig ausgeglichen
haben das getan was will ich nicht
gehalten haben wir schauen uns das
gemeinsam auch an beim profession
bericht aber wir müssen auch schauen
dass wir gezielte massen auf die unten
und mittlere einkommen helfen und auf
die frage die ich dargestellt aber der
ganze leider keine antwort gegeben 1
noch als letztes der pferdefuß denen die
mehrwertsteuersenkung harpstedt im
antrag hier auch drin nämlich die
weitergabe die nicht gesichert ist die
gerade ihre inflations getriebenen
umfeld zu hohen mitnahmeeffekten führt
und dann 13 milliarden euro kosten würde
verpuffen könnten das wollen wir nicht
insofern ist das nicht die richtige
maßnahme wir werden natürlich noch mal
in dem team das noch mal genauer
anschauen aber fein ist
zum schluss gekommen die in anderen
gesprächen abzulehnen dankeschön
[Applaus]